[Musique]
bonsoir à tous lundi 8 avril bienvenue
pour le début de cette nouvelle semaine
d'information locale avec tv 78 tout de
suite les titres de ce set 8 journal la
ville de guyancourt ouvre de nouveaux
espaces pour les familles l'inauguration
de ce relais d'assistance maternelle et
du lieu d'accueil enfants parents s'est
déroulée samedi ils sont situés dans les
locaux de l'ancien pm y ait des services
nommé en l'honneur de deux femmes
madeleine brès et joséphine baker leur
volonté démocratiser l'art contemporain
des étudiants en master à lui vécu
viennent de lancer un service de
location d'oeuvres il est possible pour
les particuliers les entreprises de les
louer pour un ou deux mois un projet
auquel s'est associée une vingtaine
d'artistes de la région et avec le
retour des beaux jours le jardin aussi
reprend vie quels sont les bons gestes à
adopter pour entretenir son gazon et ses
plantations nous sommes allés glaner
quelques conseils aux jardins de la
vallée à magny les hameaux et des
invités également en plateau les
enseignants qui ne lâche pas la
mobilisation contre le projet de loi
pour une école de la confiance
et puis le mouvement européen des
yvelines qui organise une réunion ce
jeudi à plaisir le thème est les
subventions européennes au niveau local
avant de développer ses titres cette
information qui est témoigne peut être
encore du mal être actuel des policiers
des yvelines une fonctionnaire de la
brigade de nuit de conflans sainte
honorine a mis fin à ses jours avec son
arme de service est le suicide s'est
produit dans la nuit de samedi à
dimanche dans une forêt en eure et loir
est le corps de l'agent découvert le
dimanche matin par ses collègues âgé de
37 ans mère de deux enfants elle a
laissé une lettre expliquant son geste
l'enquêté a été confiée à la brigade de
gendarmerie locale c'est le quatrième
suicide d'un policier des yvelines
en un an le troisième déjà depuis à
début 2010 neuf autres faits qui se sont
déroulés également dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche une jeune étudiante de
20 ans a été violée près de la gare de
saint quentin en yvelines à montigny le
bretonneux et vers 2 heures du matin un
individu d'une vingtaine d'années l'a
d'abord agressé avant d'abuser d'elle
dans un endroit isolé et de prendre la
fuite la victime a été conduite aux
urgences du centre hospitalier de
versailles est la brigade de sûreté
d'elancourt est en charge de l'enquêté
elle de nouveaux espaces familiaux à
guyancourt inauguration samedi dernier
du relais d'assistants 1
maternelle madeleine brès et du lieu
d'accueil enfants parents josefina baker
des sites installés au sein de
l'ancienne pmi le récit de nicolas
landry deux femmes engagées auprès des
enfants pour deux espaces familiaux de
guyancourt d'un côté madeleine brès
premier docteur en médecine devenu
pédiatre de l'autre l'artiste joséphine
baker mère de douze enfants adoptés de
nom donné au nouveau lieu d'accueil
enfants parents et relais d'assistants
maternels des espaces inauguré samedi 6
avril avec la présence de trois enfants
de joséphine baker
moi je suis très fier de la famille et
aussi que l'on pense à célébrer ou
honorer le nom de ma mère dans des lieux
consacré à l'enfance et aussi à la
tolérance
ces deux espaces dédiés à la petite
enfance et à la parentalité viennent
compléter l'offre de services de la
commune dans ces domaines cela permet
aussi d'avoir des échanges entre parents
et parfois pour sa part ans c'est
l'occasion de sortir un petit peu
d'isolement quand ils sont un peu seuls
chez eux notamment quand les enfants
sont pas encore nés et scolarisés ou
alors dans une structure telle que la
crèche pour le rhum basse et elles
savent et ont demandé à ce poste
maternelle puisque on a une centaine
d'assistantes maternelles sur la ville
aujourd'hui ce sont des démunis pour que
leurs enfants puissent avoir un lien un
échange avec d'autres assistantes
maternelles la caisse d'allocations
familiales a contribué à ce projet
notamment avec un investissement de 109
mille euros c'est évident qu'on ne peut
pas laisser les parents seuls
dans cette grande tâche parce qu'on
n'est pas par an on le devient avant
toute chose ces deux nouveaux services
vont fonctionner en alternance sur le
même site
dans l'actualité du moment la colère des
enseignants toujours présentes jeudi
dernier les professeurs du secondaire et
surtout ceux du premier degré étaient
dans la rue pour manifester contre les
projets actuels mené par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer heures on en parle avec vous
bertrand mesure bonsoir lancement est le
secrétaire départemental du snuipp fsu
le syndicat d'enseignants du premier
degré snuipp fsu au niveau des yvelines
alors plusieurs motifs pour cette colère
en premier lieu bien sûr ce projet de
loi pour une école de la confiance
l'objectif affiché par le gouvernement
c'est de relever le niveau global des
élèves
elle met aussi à assurer plus de justice
sociale au travers de l'école d'un point
de vue général pourquoi vous êtes contre
ce projet de loi
ben parce que tout simplement il est a
contrario des intentions affichées le
fait d'établir au travers de ce projet
de loi un système à plusieurs vitesses
ne peut que renforcer les inégalités qui
sont déjà très forte dans le système
france inter vous n'êtes pas contre
finalement les objectifs mais plutôt les
moyens quand sow d'honneur à venir qui
serait content les objectifs c'est
manifestement une politique très libéral
ce qu'on appelle une politique de
l'offre dans les études sociologiques
ont démontré que au lieu de diminuer les
inégalités ne faisait que le renforcer
alors dans ce projet de loi plusieurs
choses sont prévues l'instruction
obligatoire des à trois ans la refonte
également de la formation des
enseignants et notamment un point qui
suscite pas mal de mécontentement c'est
la création des jeux psf des
établissements publics des savoirs
fondamentaux de regrouperait autour d'un
collège
toutes les écoles du secteur du même
bassin de vie qui serait donc fusionner
dans cet ensemble
qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète précisément
sur ce point alors les deux choses qui
nous inquiète la première c'est le fait
que la fusion va faire disparaître en
partie la spécificité du premier degré
et l'école maternelle
l'autre élément c'est que le lien de
proximité qui s'habille entre les
directrices et les directeurs avec les
familles
lui aussi va se diluer dans un ensemble
plus vaste l'autre élément qui est
évident mais que monsieur blanc caire ne
met pas en avant c'est les économies
qu'il va pouvoir réaliser il faut savoir
que ce type de projet existait déjà sous
le gouvernement sarkozy à l'époque
monsieur blanquet était déjà aux
manettes et ça consistait en fait à
donner un pouvoir extrêmement important
au chef d'établissement et en
particulier ce vide pouvoir recruter des
contractuels
vous dites de proximité c'est à dire
qu'avec ce projet l'école ne répondrai
plus à sa mission de service public
alors écoutez ce qui est certain c'est
que ça va être une école à deux vitesses
comme je le disais tout à l'heure
puisque ça permettra de faire des
économies d'échelle de casser les
éléments de périmètres scolaires et puis
d'imposer des modalités de
fonctionnement qui ne sont pas celles du
premier degré auquel les parents sont
particulièrement attachés ans précise
juste que dans une lettre adressée aux
enseignants jean michel blanquer a
garanti le maintien maintien de la
fonction de directeur d école qui était
l'une des inquiétudes affichées aussi
que la création finalement de ces eps f
dépendrait de la volonté des
municipalités des conseils d'école qui
devrait parvenir à des accords pour les
créer ces précisions ça ne nous rassure
pas pas du tout parce que déjà nous
n'avons plus aucune confiance en ce
ministre et quand il a écrit un courrier
au directeur il s'est appuyé sur la
réforme des rythmes scolaires pour dire
par exemple que l'accord des conseils
d'école avait été demandée or c'est
parfaitement faux il le sait l'avis des
conseils d'école a été demandée et cet
avis la plupart du temps a été bafoué
donc quand monsieur blanc caire dit
qu'il va mettre en oeuvre le même
dispositif et à demander l'accord des
conseils d'école pour les eps f on ne
peut que douter d'autant plus que le psf
ça comme ça suppose quand même l'accord
entre les deux collectivités locales de
rattachement et on voit mal comment une
fois cet accord acquis les conseils
d'école pourrait être consultés et
donner un accord
voilà c'est tout à fait illusoire et sa
relève tout a fait d des bobards et de
l'embrouillé que monsieur puisqu'il aime
bien ce type de termes que monsieur
blanc caire m diffusé pour laisser
passer ses projets sur le calendrier
juste pour préciser que le projet a été
adopté en première lecture à l'assemblée
nationale que les sénateurs vont
l'examiner
en mai quelques vous demandez
aujourd'hui concrètement qu'ils soient
tout simplement retiré en demande
clairement qu'ils soient retirés il n'y
a eu absolument aucune concertation en
amont
l'un des articles de loi aussi qui nous
inquiète le plus ce qui est peut-être
pas le celui qui est le plus médiatisé
c'est la possibilité de réaliser des
expérimentations sans aucune contrainte
et sans aucune limite
ça ne peut qu'appuyer le projet de psf
et également le projet de réforme de la
fonction publique qui lui aussi va
permettre d'inscrire les vacataires et
puis une casse de la fonction publique
et des services publics au coeur de
l'état vous avez pu rencontrer les
services de l'éducation nationale sur le
sujet les services de l'éducation
nationale pour l'instant ne se prononce
pas puisque la loi n'est pas votée
j'ajouterai que monsieur blanc caire
s'était promis de ne pas faire de loi il
en fait une qui est une vraie caisse à
outil qui permettra de réaliser cette
école à plusieurs vitesses et de casser
le service public d'éducation alors sur
la mobilisation de jeudi dernier deux
chiffres en forcément ceux des autorités
15% de manifestants jeudi d'après
ministère de l'éducation nationale pour
le premier degré 25 % d'après votre
syndicat ça c'est au niveau national ce
qui est sûr ce temps en tout cas par
rapport à la journée du 19 mars et une
mobilisation en légère baisse est ce que
ça ça vous inquiète non et encelade est
de vendre pour basculer deux
mobilisations étaient extrêmement
proches ça signifie plutôt que d'un
grand nombre de collègues qui s'étaient
mobilisés le 19 mars se sont aussi
mobilisés
début avril et ça signifie la grande
crainte qu'il y a j'ajouterai que cette
crainte est partagée par les parents
puisque vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que
énormément de règlement public au lieu
nous en avons fait une attrape où il y
avait une centaine de personnes
il va y en avoir une à la verrière
demain il y en a une à la
queue-lez-yvelines tout le monde est
inquiet les parents mais également pour
les professeurs du second degré on va
bien sûr les professeurs du second degré
sont en plein dans la dans la réforme du
lycée dans la réforme de la voie
professionnelle qui manifestent
clairement l'impossibilité qu'il y a de
mettre en place ces réformes
sauf pour quelques établissements qui
vont pouvoir en profiter pleinement
donc pour renforcer là encore le
caractère inégalitaire des projets de
monsieur blanc crème d'autres
mobilisations prévues vous avez pas
lâcher leur écoute et les mobilisations
sont prévues
jeudi à trappes nous allons faire
l'enterrement de l'éducation nationale
vendredi monsieur blanc caire vient pas
des gendarmes ça ne s'invente pas donc
nous irons à son deux ans pour dire tout
le bien parce parents et enseignants que
nous pensons de sa réforme
j'ajoute que ça concerne l'ensemble des
personnels de l'éducation nationale
premier et second degrés merci bertrand
mesure je rappelle que vous êtes le
secrétaire départemental du snuipp fsu
dans les yvelines de l'école à
l'université celle de
versailles-saint-quentin direction sa
bibliothèque à guyancourt il est
désormais possible de louer des oeuvres
d'art pour un ou deux mois les
collections de cette première artothèque
viennent d'être dévoilées un service
destiné aussi bien aux particuliers
qu'aux entreprises mélanie poker et
aurélie 11
et si ce tableau où cette photo prenez
place temporairement dans votre salon
dans la salle de réunion de votre
entreprise
artaud cher une association étudiants de
l'ue vs qu vient de lancer un service de
location d'oeuvres d'art sa mission
démocratiser l'art contemporain le but
du coup c'est vraiment de mettre l'art
au coeur du quotidien des étudiants mais
aussi des habitants de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines et plus largement
des entreprises puisque notre vie c'est
aussi de les toucher
cette artothèque s'inscrit dans le cadre
d'un projet d'étudiants de master en
management des organisations culturelles
et artistiques
elle est hébergée au rez-de-chaussée de
la bibliothèque universitaire de saint
quentin en yvelines
notre rôle consiste surtout à les aider
à pouvoir rencontrer un public et donc
pour ça leur mettre à disposition un
local travailler avec eux pour des
règles de prêt pour pour une
organisation administrative qui puisse
rendre possible le prêt et la vente des
oeuvres qu'ils nous qui nous présente
que l'on soit étudiant particulier ou
une entreprise
le tarif de location de retards varient
entre 10 et 1200 euros
au total une vingtaine d'artistes
contemporains de la région ont collaboré
pour enrichir le catalogue on emprunte
bien des livres alors pourquoi ne pas
emprunter des oeuvres je trouve c'est un
biais qui est complémentaire à celui de
la visite muséal ou d'expositions ou
même de l'achat moi j'ai choisi un grand
colis petit camp cinq pièces et je les
choisis parce que je me suis dit aussi
qu'il pourrait être loué en une deux
trois quatre cinq pièces selon les
espaces on voudrait le maître espace de
découvertes de rencontres et de partage
l'artothèque est ouverte tous les
mercredis et samedis de 13h à 16h un
mode économie valeo leader des brevets
en france pour la troisième année
consécutive l'équipementier automobile
arrive en tête du palmarès de l'institut
national de la propriété industrielle
avec un 1355 brevets publiés en 2018 un
travail mené dans l'électrification des
voitures le véhicule autonome et la
mobilité digital group compte 59 centres
de recherche et développement à travers
le monde dont un qui est située dans les
yvelines à la verrière les élections
européennes approchent c'est le 26 mai
prochain en france alors pour mieux
comprendre lieu je vous invite à
retrouver sur tv 78 ans comme à notre
dernier 7,8 dossier consacré à cette
thématique est aussi chaque mois l
émission le 7-8 l'europe présentée par l
nicolas kirillovitch autre solution elle
c'est une conférence a retrouvé jeudi
prochain la maison des sports de plaisir
elle vous aidera à y voir plus clair sur
les subventions européennes et plus
concrètement que finance le haut niveau
local pour y répondre on a deux invités
avec moi autour de la table des dizianes
boussier bonsoir vous est la
cofondatrice du mouvement européen
l'antenne de saint quentin en yvelines
du mouvement
européens et vous êtes également sa vice
présidente au niveau des yvelines est
également philippe le guen bonsoir soir
vous êtes membre du conseil
d'administration du mouvement européen
des yvelines coordinateur adjoint de la
maison de l'europe à la maison jean
monnet pardon la maison de jean monnet à
bazoches sur guyonne qui est rattaché à
la direction générale de la
communication du parlement européen des
gens un mot sur le mouvement européen
pour les téléspectateurs qui ne
connaissent pas ce mouvement quelles
sont ses missions le lower européen est
donc né en 1949 après la après la guerre
c'est un mouvement disons pluraliste
tranche politique qui est un lieu de
débat entre tous les courants politiques
il aide à connaître l'europe il organise
des débats entre les citoyens ils
proposent ils informent voilà ce qu'il
est et sur l'île ya donc cinquante
section locale d'accord dans le nouveau
mot râpé 1 dont celle de saint quentin
qui est née il ya en février 2018 voilà
et co fondée par russian frank et moi
même et donc depuis depuis cette époque
on organise des conférences des débats
dans le secteur mais on imagine dans les
têtes forcément en ce moment ces
élections européennes qui prennent qui
prennent toute la place
il ya beaucoup d'événements qui qui se
multiplient en ce moment pour parler de
l'europe pour par des millions
européenne ça commence dès réécouter ses
lancers vous savez que le 26 mai en
france nous serons appelés aux urnes
pour renouveler les les députés
européens français
bon cette année pour ces élections c'est
le choix qui a été fait par le
gouvernement c'est d'avoir une liste
nationale
une seule circonscription de seule
circonscription celle de la france vont
avec évidemment une pluralité de parti
politique donc on s'est aperçu qu'en mai
mais avec le mouvement européen
et nous mêmes à la maison jean monnet
qui accueillons beaucoup le public que
les citoyens connaissent peu voire pas
du tout le fonctionnement du parlement
européen qui pourtant votent les lois
européennes qui s'applique dans tous les
états membres qui sont transposés dans
là dans le droit des français en
particulier de prothèses et amant donc
il paraît important de toujours
expliquer le fait de la pédagogie final
à de la pédagogie est quelque chose de
très concret bien que fait l'europe
peut-être au quotidien au plus près de
nous donc c'est le thème du colloque en
effet je suis habitants de saint quentin
en yvelines que fait l'europe pour moi
et alors comment se traduisent les
subventions au niveau localement
existent pour faire quoi
comment éventuellement je peux les
obtenir
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de fonds
des fonds comme le fc sion va peut-être
les voir s'afficher ces fonds européens
en tout cas les principaux le fonds
social européen
le feder fonds européen de développement
régional le feader qui est un fonds
européen agricole pour le développement
rural finalement beaucoup de fonds
l'idée c'est aussi les rendre plus
lisibles ces fonds c'est pour ça qu'il
ya c'est aussi ça les objectifs de cette
conférence
oui les rendre plus proche des citoyens
c'est à dire que on peut se demander bon
finalement j'habite là dans un an
dans cette rue qu'est ce que fait
l'europe en face de chez moi
de l'autre côté de la rue et bien
l'europe peut très bien à travers les
fonds que vous avez cité notamment le
fonds de développement régional
cofinancer des des mesures pour la
rénovation de l'habitat pour le rendre
plus conforme aux normes
environnementales peut très bien avec le
fse et bien finalement créer des emplois
avec des start up qui peuvent est
justement en face de chez moi et qui
peuvent me rendre un service
et puis aussi réaménager le territoire
on est dans une zone
évidemment ici qui est proche aussi du
monde rural et bien le feader ça vient
aussi réorganiser l'agriculture de
demain la repenser pour en faire des
agriculteurs des développeurs du
territoire favoriser aussi peut-être la
transition écologique la transition
énergétique qui t'a fait puisque ce sont
tous tous ces fonds servent finalement
sur le terrain à cofinancer des mesures
qui sont décidés dans les grandes
politiques européennes qui se traduise
ensuite dans les états membres barre des
programmes d'action et ses pointes
d'actions sont cofinancés par l'europe
je dis bien qu'au financement il faut
évidemment aussi obtenir les des fonds
publics ou privés français justement
pour terminer viviane négociations prend
l'exemple de saint quentin en yvelines
quel type de projet ont pu être financés
grâce à grâce à l'europe
quel exemple vous pouvez nous donner si
l'écouté des projets il y en a pas mal
disons que et pour compléter un petit
peu en plus des fonds il ya aussi tous
ces programmes communautaires auxquels
il faut les ajouter jusqu'à erasmus qui
je crois va doubler ou tripler la
période qui vient donc ils touchent les
étudiants de 50 ares puisqu'il y en a
300 parents qui partent à peu près
depuis 50 ans sans compter tout ce qui
est aussi programme pour les plus
démunis dont on parle très peu et qui
qui existent aussi qu'ils financent
aussi bien des restos du coeur
la croix rouge mais pour en revenir dans
qu'à votre question sur de façon plus
pratique sur les sur les fonds européens
donc la saint quentin soutien quatre
axes aides à la création d'entreprise
c'est ainsi qu'elle intervient sur ce
cube nom qui a dit l'incubateur qui est
là qu à dormir dans des start up de
saint-quentin donc dans cette optique
que tu disais c'est à dire soutenir
l'innovation la croissance
les jeunes startups le pour l'aca
contribuer à l'égalité des chances c'est
un des axes forts de 50 ha dans ce
domaine contre la fracture numérique
c'est le cas par exemple pour le campus
numérique
c'est le cas pour glee en cours mais
avec son son espace public numérique est
l'un des rivaux puisque on arrive à la
fin de cet entretien telle demande est
peut-être que tu disais la rénovation
thermique nom d'allah pour les logements
il ya eu je crois deux programmes sur
montigny un programme sur trapped in
souvenirs sûrement un programme celui en
cours avec des sommes assez conséquent
pour terminer le ces exemples d'abord
faire venir du cou à cette conférence
qui se déroule ce jeudi à 18 heures à la
maison des sports de plaisir alors je
précise que c'est derrière le centre
sportif pierre de coubertin toutes les
informations sur le site du mouvement
européen des yvelines et vous pouvez
réserver via le lien qui s'est affichée
durant cet entretien à merci c'est à 18h
c'est à 18h merci des lianes russia
merci merci à vous philippe le guen
d'être passé sur ce plateau les
directions poissy à présent ds est has
des classes à horaires aménagés sportive
offriront dès la rentrée de septembre
elle a cité scolaire le corbusier
accueillera 50 jeunes dans un premier
temps uniquement sur le secteur
pisciacais à terme ce sont 200 jeunes
qui pourront intégrer ces classes ils
pourront y suivre une scolarité normale
au collège ou au lycée avec trois après
midi libre par semaine pour s'adonner à
la pratique sportive 13 disciplines sont
concernées du handball au football en
passant par le kung fu ou encore le
triathlon l'objectif c'est de faire
réussir ses élèves dans leur scolarité
tout en continuant leur projet sportif
une idée de
une idée qui est une idée qui est née
entre la mairie et l'établissement
scolaire où pas moins de 18 sportifs de
haut niveau sont passés les propos sont
repris par michael et demi d'euros nous
avons un environnement à des structures
sportives autour de poissy et sur rossi
relativement intéressante et notamment
le club de triathlon et ces jeunes ne
bénéficie pas d'un temps suffisant
d'aménagement pour s'entraîner
correctement et avoir donc j'en veux
dire un palmarès où un parcours encore
plus ambitieux donc la réflexion a été
de voir comment est ce que nous pouvions
consignes et l'activité sportive et la
réussite scolaires en aménageant un
emploi du temps le temps est un critère
très important pour le parcours des
jeunes pour le parcours de leurs de leur
double projet on s'aperçoit rapidement
que lorsqu'un sportif veut aller vers
l'excellence sportive
la condition de du projet scolaire est
rapidement mis en difficulté donc si le
temps est étudiée optimisé est bien
calibré avec le soutien des associations
la réussite du parcours sportif du jeune
et tout de suite devient tout de suite
c'est une évidence
[Musique]
notre journaliste sportif quel est le
héros que l'on retrouve tout de suite
bonsoir on sait gré de l'actualité
sportive du week-end les principaux
résultats
on va commencer par du football
exactement match changea plaisir le club
local recevait carrière grésillons
demi-finale de la coupe des yvelines
après une première période rythmée ciel
ce sont finalement les visiteurs qui
ouvrent le score sur un pénalty 1 à 0 ce
sera le score à la mi-temps deuxième
période les affaires de plaisir ne
s'arrange pas on voit le premier penalty
justement voilà à grégory donc en
deuxième période les affaires de plaisir
ne s'arrange pas il concède un deuxième
penalty s'incline finalement 2 à 0 en
écoute les réactions très déçu très déçu
après c'est le football hand on va
commencer par féliciter carrière baca
qui a mérité sa qualification qu'en se
qualifiant le mérite donc bravo à eux
d'abord on a mis les ingrédients pour
gagner ce match on a quarante cinq
premières minutes qui était à peu près
équilibrées on prend un premier but sur
un petit détail presse on reste quand
même dans le match je trouve que la
deuxième mi temps on a totalement dominé
l'adversaire on a eu pas mal d'occasions
nettes on a touché la barre le gardien
aussi il était sur quelques cons on n'a
vraiment pas eu de chance pour plaisir
il faudra espérer avoir un peu plus de
chance l'année prochaine pour soulever
la coupe
de son côté carrière grésillons
rencontrera le club de vélizy en finale
de la coupe des yvelines le 16 juin
prochain à verneuil-sur-seine l on parle
course à pied à présent dimanche 7 avril
à lui en cours certains se sont levés
très tôt pour participer à la 25e
édition de la bulle en course au départ
du gymnase des droits de l'homme
une course à pied de 10 km celui qui a
le mieux réussi son réveil matinal c'est
lui pierre etienne charbonnel il
remporte la course en 38 minutes et 40
secondes pour sa première participation
en l'écoutent
le deuxième est juste à queue devait pas
très loin on a fait dix bornes ensemble
et puis j'ai un peu décroché sur le
sur le dernier kilomètre mais c'était
très bien rendez vous l'année prochaine
pour une 26e édition les organisateurs
pourrait modifier légèrement le parcours
est intégrée de la marche nordique au
programme de l'événement et la victoire
chez les féminines victoire chez les
féminines audrey soulabaille qui a
remporté la compétition
alors je vais vous dire exactement le
temps 43 minutes et 57 secondes
on retrouve cette interview et son
interview et et l'ensemble des
reportages sport du week-end dans votre
étude sport c'est après ce journal on
referme d'ailleurs un ce journal avec ce
dernier un reportage avec les beaux
jours qui reviennent vous avez peut être
envie de profiter de votre jardin et de
lui redonner vie ni quel ennemi doro
justement et marylène iapichino sont
allés glaner quelques conseils à magny
les hameaux
je voudrais de la ligne
d
transformer son jardin d'hiver pour le
printemps première étape son gazon pour
lui redonner un petit coup de verre un
peu d'engrais on va se créer des lignes
droites dans notre gazon c'est la baisse
et le le geste auguste du semeur le
paysagiste effectué deux passages un
premier par ligne puis dans la
perpendiculaire
cela permet une répartition homogène et
d'éviter la catastrophe
la brûlure de sa pelouse une opération a
effectué fin février et a renouvelé en
septembre pour un meilleur entretien on
voit un gazon qui repart quand même bien
il n'y a pas trop de mousse parce que il
ay là il a ces deux apports d'engrais
par an et pourtant on est on est un
endroit où on a une terre argileuse
si la terre argileuse du bassin et d'une
loi n'est pas des plus propices aux
bêtes que je vous
elle est en revanche idéal pour les
arbustes n'hésitez pas à leur faire de
la place dans vos massifs mais avant
plantation on l'habille son art must
rhabiller c'est le retail et légèrement
avant la plantation pour qui les maîtres
du bois et de la racine
une fois ces branches mortes coupe et on
peut le sortir de son pot pour vérifier
et déployer légèrement ses racines en
blanc voyez c'est un végétal qui qui se
porte très bien c'est ce qu'on appelle
des radicelles c'est à dire les
nouvelles racines et à partir de ce
moment là une présence importante de
radicelles c'est clair buste il est prêt
à s'installer et il va partir très
rapidement lorsque vous creusez une
astuce créer une cuvette pour faciliter
l'arrosage
si on fait pas cette cuvette l'eau va
tomber et restera jamais au contact de
de la plante
l'idée c'est vraiment d'amener le lot à
la racine
l'idéal pour une nouvelle plantation est
un arrosage deux fois par semaine de
l'équivalent d'un seau d'eau pour sa
toute première tétée laplante a même
besoin d'un arrosage jusqu'au refus il
faut attendre ce phénomène pour pour
considérer que l'arrosage est bien
réalisé enfin n'oubliez pas vos plantes
qu'il faudra battre comme se remarque un
qui a besoin de petites coupes
vous pouvez toujours les garder pour
votre premier barbecue de l'année et
c'est la fin de ce journal belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]